- Welcome everyone.
Today I'm standing in front of
my old university in Munich.
Here I completed my undergraduate studies.
So old memories for
sure are coming up here.
And the video of today
is about time management.
I am sharing with you my insights
on how to manage your time right.
How to get your time management
the way it should be.
And indeed, there's lots
of information out there
available on the topic.
There's the Pomodoro technique,
calendar blocking, getting things done,
lots of project management tips like this.
And I believe that actually
most of them do not work.
Most of these things are not effective.
Most of these things will not get you
where you wanna be at.
So today I'm sharing exactly these things
because I tried many of these things out.
And indeed my personal insight is that,
even though you might spend
some time trying it out,
in the end they will not deliver you
the results that you need.
My name is Heinrich
and welcome on my channel, "Firm Learning"
where I want to help you
to become successful in the
first years of your career.
And the reason why I'm here
at University of Munich,
when I'm talking about time management,
is that here it is exactly
where I personally got my
first insights on the topic.
And indeed, when I started
in my undergraduate,
I studied for two
independent bachelor programs
at the same time,
bachelor in philosophy and
the bachelor in business.
I completed both within
the regular study period.
Of course I was also part
of different extracurricular activities.
I spent a semester abroad
at the University of
Milan, Bocconi University.
So one could argue that,
maybe I'm not too bad at time management.
But what did I do?
What crazy techniques that did I use?
And the reason is, the
truth is, I didn't use any
of these special time
management techniques.
And this is one of the later learned
the exact same thing that is true
for working in consulting.
During my time at McKinsey,
of course, most consultants
were pretty productive.
If you just look at the
output of these people
add the things that these people get done.
Yes. One could argue that they must have
crazy time management
techniques some place
to get all this done.
And of course they will use
basic project management
best practices, such as
having, to do lists, checklist,
project management techniques like that,
but they are not using any Pomodoro,
calendar blocking techniques like that.
This is just not what is happening.
So what is the common
thing that both I did
at the university of Munich,
and then later all the people do
that are working in consulting.
What are they doing right
to manage their time when it's not
all these crazy techniques that
everybody is talking about?
So the one key factor that really keeps
consultants productive, is just pressure,
external pressure, external commitments.
This is just the truth.
This is what it's all about.
And indeed many people
struggle with procrastination.
And for sure, I might suffer from that
in my private life as well.
But why is it the case,
that if you work in consulting
or in any other high paced career,
why is it the case that
in these environments
nobody is suffering from procrastination,
I can tell you.
And the main reason is,
that just people need to deliver.
Every single day, there is
an important client meeting,
an important internal
problem solving session.
The next vehicle that you need to prepare
you are just under
pressure for the whole day.
This is what keeps you productive.
And indeed there is a law that
probably some of you also know
it's called Parkinson's law.
And this law says that the
work that you will need to do
will always take up all the time
that you allocate to that work.
So if you need to achieve
and complete something
if you have an hour for
it, you will, in most cases
get it done in an hour.
If you have a day for it, you will easily
be able to fill it up for a day,
because then maybe you do some breaks.
Maybe you do some other things.
You Polish it a little bit,
make it look a little bit nice
or whatever the task,
whatever the activity is.
But in the end, the result
will be more or less the same
it just took you much,
much longer to complete it.
And I had the very same
experience when I studied here
at university of Munich
for my undergraduate
programs, what kept me
productive were not crazy
time management techniques.
It was just the pressure
of needing to complete
all these different things
in a short amount of time.
Same is true in consulting.
It's not about time management techniques
but just the deadlines and the
pressure that you are facing.
And indeed, another
concept that really plays
into this is the concept of adaptation.
So I remember when I worked in consulting
of course everybody
was working long hours.
You are often sitting after midnight
just leaving lots of work
that needed to be done.
Then I did the MBA.
I had a break for about one year.
And of course, then
the whole life changed.
We had lots of time with all
the students during the MBA.
And suddenly I remember days
where I had three lectures
on one day, how tired I felt.
I felt this was the
most exhausting day ever
only because I was sitting in
three lectures on a given day.
And again, I'll remember
when then after the MBA
I was back in consulting and I
was on my very first project.
And again, the first days,
the first one or two weeks
it just was so difficult.
I felt so tired after this time.
I remember sitting at home
and I thought to myself
I cannot do it.
It's just too much.
I cannot handle this anymore.
This is just not the job. I asked myself
how was I able to deal with this, to bear
with this in the past,
but then after one or two
or three weeks, again,
you went back to normal.
You just got used to it again.
So here are the key
messages you get used to it.
If you feel tired, if you
feel you cannot do more
you have too much pressure.
It's always relative to your
level of tasks and activities.
If you're just used to do more
you will also able to do more.
So this is just the key
insight that you need to
understand your ability
to get more work done
will not depend on any
time management techniques
but just the number of
things, the amount of work
that you have on your plate
and that you need to complete
not tomorrow
not a week from now a month
from now, but right now.
So having said that you might say Heinrich
well that makes sense.
Hopefully you agree with that
but how can we make this practical?
This is pretty theoretical
after all, Isn't it?
So let me share with you three
tangible tips, three pieces
of advice on how you can
implement this in your daily life.
First is compatibility of tasks.
So try to pick different activities
different tasks that are
complimentary to each other
and do not necessarily conflict.
So when I was in university
and studied philosophy
and business, in business
it was the case that at
the end of every semester
there were lots of exams I needed to take.
In philosophy on the other
hand, during the semester
there were term papers,
coursework assignment
that I needed to complete.
So what this meant is that
during the semester I needed
to focus on philosophy
getting these term papers out.
And then at the end of the semester
I was able to focus on business,
on the business exams because
there hardly were any exams
in my philosophy undergrad at all.
So while I was able to do all these things
in parallel time-wise they
did not really collide.
They were complimentary to each other.
And this is also important for you.
If you look at all the things
that you might be interested
in doing, can you pick things
that really go well together?
If you're able to pick activities
which are not in conflict to each other
but can really leverage your
dead time in the evenings
or on the weekends, this
is what we're really
make the difference for
you in the long-term.
My second advice is to
deliberately put yourself
in situations where you're
creating external commitments.
And here, again, sharing a personal story.
So several years ago
I was not really a sportive person at all.
I was rarely doing any sport
and while today I'm still
not the fittest guy.
At least I managed to pick
up a regular running habit.
And in the last year
it's usually that I managed
to finish two marathons.
And for me there was one thing that really
made the difference
in picking up this regular training habit.
And this was signing up to the marathon
or before that signing
up to the half marathon.
Once I had this date locked
well I knew that I would
go there, take the run.
And also some friends joining
me, suddenly I had a reason.
I had a higher purpose
of why I was training, why I was running.
And just by that alone
I was able to then exercise
several days a week
just improve my form to
get ready for that event.
So now every year
I try to register myself for
one of these running events
just to have a reason to
have a goal, to run towards.
You know, translate that
to your areas where you're
wanting to be successful.
What can you do to
create these commitments
to create this artificial
external pressure
to hold you accountable?
And the little things that
you can do are to talk
about these things, to other people
to maybe even find an
accountability partner
with whom you regularly talk
about these things and
make your commitments.
Don't just keep it in
head, but make it public
create external commitments
to keep your cultivated.
And my third and maybe most
important tip that at least
for me personally,
really worked well is to
try to always to commit
to more things always try
to get more things done than you believe
you're realistically really able to do.
And if you do that, then yes,
maybe some things will fail.
Maybe you will not be
able to achieve every
little thing that you want to,
but then if you aim for 200%
at least to get 150% done.
On the other hand from the
beginning, you're only aiming
for the a hundred percent
due to Parkinson's law,
you're likely still
will not even be able to
achieve this a hundred percent.
So deliberately overload
yourself with goals,
with activities be okay to maybe fail
with some of these things.
So accept that job.
Sign up for that sports
training group take on
this extra voluntary leadership commitment
in your community, commit to work
on your own personal business project
in the evenings or on the weekend.
And yes, if you do all that,
maybe not everything will
work the way you hope to,
but I would be very surprised
if you do others, it would
not get done much more
than if you only take it slow
and not do all these
things from the beginning.
So hope that there were
some interesting points
that you took away from this as always
if you have any questions at
all, leave me a comment below
in the comment section,
I will do my very best
to answer every single
comment that you write.
And yes, every comment also helps me
with the YouTube algorithm.
Also let me know whether
you like this video
on time management
whether you want to see
more from me on the topic.
So if you took any value
out of this video at all
please destroy the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to the channel
to stay up to date on all my content.
I have a mailing list, signup
link in the video description.
Also I have an Instagram
my handle is Firm Learning.
And actually my wife once
created a little workbook
on time management with lots
of little tips and tricks and advice.
So if you're interested in that
have a look and its
linked in the description.
Now a big thank you
to all the members of this
channel Firm Learning.
You are really making a big difference
through this work and supporting
the cause of the channel.
So if you want to become a member as well
hit the join button next
to the subscribe button
to learn what it's all
about and also learn
about the member only
perks that you will get.
Thank you so much for watching.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning.
I'm releasing new videos
every single Saturday.
So good weekend to you until next week.
Bye Heinrich here.